- First the good news:
cloud development strategies mean more
and faster deployments.
Now the bad news:
more and faster deployments
can impact your IT operations
team, increasing the time
to resolve incidents.
That potentially means unhappy
customers and more resources
dedicated to keeping your
systems running smoothly.
Hi, I'm Dan Kehn from IBM Cloud®.
So what's your ops team to do?
I'll cover that question in
two quick demonstrations,
but first let's briefly review the phases
of incident resolution, then
I'll explain how automation
and AI can help.
Mean time to resolution
is the big picture.
It covers everything from the
time the problem has started
until it's finally resolved.
The longer it takes to resolve,
the worse the impact to your organization.
Some parts of resolution
time are consistent,
like mean time to fix, or MTTF.
Others vary significantly,
like mean time to identify,
or MTTI, which can run from hours to days.
That's because it relies
on operators' experience
and knowledge of the system relationships.
To help lower MTTI, IBM
Cloud Pak® for Watson AIOps
comes with built-in anomaly
identification strategies
that use machine learning.
Of course, machine learning
works best when there's lots
of varied, high-quality data.
That's why Cloud Pak for
Watson AIOps consumes data
from many sources, it
then uses AI to discover
relationships across these
different data sources
and weigh possible causes.
This unsupervised learning
reduces the time needed
to realize the value of AI,
so instead of requiring
extensive training,
you can get started right away,
with out-of-the-box, pre-trained models.
Okay, with that intro out of the way,
I'd like to walk you through
two incidents and how
Cloud Pak for Watson
AIOps can help you resolve
them more quickly.
The first I call lucky day.
With the smart search of prior solutions,
you close the incident using
documented steps in a run book.
The second, which unfortunately
happens more often
than we'd like to admit,
I call not-so-lucky day.
This is an undiscovered
problem that requires sifting
through misbehaving servers
and confirming the root cause.
Imagine you're at lunch and a notification
from Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps comes in.
You double click to check it out.
In the problem summary, you
recognize one of the services
you monitor, so you decide to investigate.
Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps
shows you a summary view
based on data gathered directly
from your app monitoring
logs and from integrated
tools like PagerDuty, Splunk,
and ServiceNow.
The chat entry shows you
several different fields.
First, the impacted application,
the train ticket application.
Next, a hypothesized
storage of the problem,
the ticket info service.
It also shows you incident
severity and status.
Finally, you can see a summary
ticket that was automatically
generated by Watson AIOps.
Two key questions for resolving
a problem are what changed
and what happened nearby?
Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps groups events
that represent change and a topology map
that represents nearby connected services.
That is what changed,
how recently it changed,
and how frequently it
changed gives you hints
about the source of the problem.
With smart topology and an
understanding of the context,
you now know where to start.
Okay, I've shown you how
Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps
provides a summary of key
diagnostic information,
but it also helps consolidate information
from multiple tools across
different data silos.
This view shows a summary of
the anomalies that underlie
the problem report.
This helps reduce information overload
and avoid notification flooding.
It also saves you from the
hassle of chasing problems
across different tools.
Now that you have a better
understanding of the incident,
you take action to resolve it.
Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps
has identified similar tickets
based on data interpreted with
natural language processing
and pre-trained AI models.
This can help you quickly
identify relevant tickets
with possible solutions.
By pinpointing specific
actions that your team
has taken in the past, you
don't have to deal with the
tedium of manually reviewing
a list of prior tickets.
You confirm the run book
matches the current problem
and resolve the incident.
Excellent.
And the prior investigation, we got lucky.
The problem had been resolved once before,
so we only had to execute a run book.
But what if it wasn't so easy?
And that's where AI and
machine learning really shine.
Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps
consumes huge volumes
of your system data,
structured data like
configuration topology,
semi-structured data like
logs and ticket information,
even unstructured data
like commit comments.
Based on this data, it learns
what normal looks like so
it can alert you when metrics
are outside expected bounds.
But the metric manager in
Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps
doesn't rely on fixed threshold tracking.
This avoids the trap where
a high fixed threshold
generates too few alerts and real problems
are ignored until they become serious
or low threshold generates too many alerts
and your operators simply tune them out.
Instead, Cloud Pak for Watson
AIOps uses machine learning
to understand what's normal behavior
for key performance metrics
and automatically sets
adaptive threshold based on
actual system experience.
Now let's look at how
Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps
helps you with your not-so-lucky day.
It's later in the week and
you're handling another incident.
This time it's a claims
app and users are reporting
really bad response times.
You start your investigation by opening
the events dashboard.
Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps
recognizes many data sources
for event correlation.
For example, data from Log
DNA, Serves Now, PagerDuty
and hundreds of other integrations.
The dashboard groups related events based
on inferred associations like topology,
the time occurrence, and location.
Let's take a closer look
at the event leading up
to the claims app slowing down.
This metrics timeline can help you
with problem determination
and assess potential impacts.
The green indicates
normal behavior over time.
You can visualize baseline
performance compared
to the recently-captured data.
The secondary view shows metrics
based on application observability.
These are metrics
discovered and identified
as being related to the
app's response time.
Here we see the disk
busy metric is unstable,
let's add it to the timeline
for further investigation.
Now the primary review
shows that just before
the response time problems, the disk busy
for the storage service went up
to nearly 100% utilization
and it stayed there.
That's never good.
Based on this brief analysis,
you know the data store
for the database was overloaded.
It's a prime candidate for the root cause
of the app's slowdown.
The next step is confirming
your analysis by checking
the service logs and then
proposing a proper solution.
The analysis of the relationships
between these metrics
help you understand the
full scope of the problem.
Once the fix is delivered,
you can say with confidence,
you've identified and
resolved the true cause.
Okay, let's recap.
When it comes to IT Ops,
it's better to be proactive
than constantly being forced
into a reactive posture.
With dynamically-determined
rules, the data analysis
by Cloud Pak for Watson
AIOps helps you get
to resolution quicker,
potentially before your users
even notice a problem.
And you don't have to manage rules,
consider how they
interact with each other,
or worry about how rules should change
when the environment changes.
What can automation mean to your company?
How about 25% more time
spent on work that drives
your business or reducing
manual labor costs by 50%?
Thanks for watching.
If you'd like to see more
videos like this in the future,
please click like and subscribe.
If you want to learn more about
Cloud Pak for Watson AIOps,
make sure to check out the
links in the description.